I can sit in a room with somebody for 15
minutes and know if I've got a winner or
not and 99% of the time I'm right so I
listen to the gut and I listen to the
person I listen to the plan I know it's
gonna work or it isn't I just know I'm
that good well you know like the
serendipitous I really believe that and
how will the outcome occurs is you know
everybody has a path in their career
they plan on but it generally doesn't
work out that way there's a series of
events that happen to you along the way
and you don't know as they're happening
because you've only realized how
important they were maybe a decade later
when you realize it was a huge pivot
point for you mine was when I was
working in a summer job in college for a
pet food company and I had a German
manager a really interesting guy and he
taught me that most pet foods at that
time were made from Sea of Japan tuna
and chicken faces and beef lips and
rendered you know protein using mango
juice to crush it up sounds horrific but
those are two basic engines and then
they'd add some peas or you know some
carrots and they create cat food flavors
decades later when I was in the software
industry I realized that you know we
were the leader in math and reading
software and here's where this story
comes into play all my competitors were
spending a fortune building unique
applications to advance reading and math
scores those are the two big things you
actually create software to advance if
you're an education and I thought to
myself that's crazy this is really just
sea of japan' tuna and chicken faces all
we need are two engines and we'll just
add characters to them and that was how
the learning company became the largest
software and company in the world in
reference and education we sold over 4.2
billion but that manager gave me the
idea to synergize around to development
groups we we hired you know we buy a
company fire everybody and just take the
characters they had and we cut our costs
dramatically
you know our cost of R&D or half the
industries everybody was complaining but
how are we doing it we're doing it
because we understand that that software
is no different than
that's amazing it also sounds and I want
to dig deeper into this like what you're
good at it sounds like you're really
good at identifying patterns it sounds
like you know that was a model or
template that you used but also pattern
before you go into that I want to go
back in time a little bit too young
Kevin yeah yeah I want to talk about you
know your early origins you know your
your influences like what did you want
to be when you grew up as a young kid
what are you thinking about what
happened is around that time my father
was only 37 years old died and so that
was a very traumatic moment and my
mother remarried about two years later
and my new father was a completely
different character than my biological
one he was finishing off his master's or
than his PhD at the University of
Illinois champaign-urbana and he joined
the United Nations and we started moving
every two years to a different country
so I've lived in Cyprus Cambodia Tunisia
Ethiopia Japan England Switzerland every
24 months I mean I I met you know Paul
Pott while he was a lieutenant for C
anoke in Cambodia I've met hailey
Selassie and his lion cubs before I
became a deity these are just random
outcomes in my life but it's certainly
later as I always say you don't know
these things are happening to you but
they are for a reason and it may it's
made me a relatively successful
international investor because I was
able to see trends I mean I lived in
Cambodia I saw when the French and
Germans are going into real estate there
to follow them in I knew exactly what
the industries were in Ethiopia and what
you should invest in Cyprus I already
saw the banking system and the oil
business growing there and it was an
investor there so there's all kinds of
cues you get from your youth that you
should really apply to your business
later and that was a remarkable
experience and certainly he was a major
influence in my life because when I
graduated from high school I wanted to
be a photographer and I was really into
photography and I had my own lab
downstairs and I was doing all the
things I love to do and he said you're
not good enough you're not good enough
to be a photographer and you'll starve
to death you should go to college and
get a degree and I listened to his
advice because I thought he really
understood
and and I went on to do an MBA which
ended up being a very important tool for
me later but I went back into production
my first company was special event
television which produced all the
programming for the East Coast Hockey
feeds Bobby Orr in the hockey legend Don
Cherry's grapevine we would shoot it all
week much like we're doing right now and
then edit it and sends up to a satellite
in the you know mid 80s and I was an
editor or a producer or a cameraman I
used to work with nagra's and we had a
steenbeck editing table I did it all and
I was trying to get back to the thing I
loved which was photography and
production and make money doing it and
and there was that science and that art
coming together in my life and we sold
that company because Don Jerry's vape
vine became a very successful television
format and that was my first transaction
we sold the company in the three
founders I took that money and started
the software business that eventually
got sold for 4.2 billion things happen
in life you don't know why and you only
get to look at them in retrospect a long
time later but all of that stuff you
know made me what I am today the good
the bad and the ugly and and I wouldn't
change a thing what I pulled out from
that as well as it seems like all that
moving and all that you know uprooting
and going somewhere else you had to sort
of adapt or die right like you had to
really sort of I think it's a Bruce Lee
quote right like yeah you know you have
to be like the water in the vase you
know not the vase you have to conform to
whatever shape that you are poured into
it sounds like that's kind of what you
did and also it sounds like that
experience also made you very scrappy or
resourceful right like so you're
battling with dyslexia you're also you
know dealing with probably different
cultures and different foods and
different languages you you had to be
resourceful and creative and you know be
that water yeah yeah that's a very
intuitive way to look at it and you're
right I didn't like living in places
like Cambodia Phnom Penh I didn't want
to be sequestered with the expats that
that was not interesting for me I wanted
to live with the people and we ended up
with a couple of tutors we used the
calven system then which is a system
that is
a direct mail learning system and better
than nothing right
try to stay advanced in in high school
years but Tia and dang were a couple of
you know people in my life then that
very influential and I had a French
tutor she was from France she spoke a
little English and she tutored me you
know at home and in where we lived in
Cambodia and I and I slowly got immersed
in that culture which is a beautiful
culture Cambodian people are almost
mystical and they're beautiful and I
didn't want to hang out with everybody
from chef Cabana I want to hang out with
the Cambodians and that's what happened
I took my kids back there a couple of
years ago to show them where I grew up
and to take them into the jungle and see
how Cambodia works and that's unique
experience for them they were blown away
they've never even thought about it so
to me it's all those experiences and I
certainly in Cyprus hung out with
Cypriots you know in Ethiopia the
Ethiopians are the most remarkable
people because you're living a mile high
they're very tall very lanky they're
beautiful they obviously win almost all
the marathons they get involved in so I
got into that I didn't have a bicycle I
rode a horse I mean the first barbecue I
ever did with my family and friends the
sky turned black with vultures they'd
never smelled burning meat before that
way we had a thousand vultures circling
and I looked up and oh [ __ ] what's
happening here and that was the kind of
thing you learned just I was showing
these guys here's how you have a cookout
here's a barbecue and they said we don't
think it's a very good idea and it I
think now you know it's a great resource
for me in what as you say you're
thinking about how to do things a little
differently particularly in global
businesses I'm involved in global
financial services now I just came back
from Dubai last week in Manila you know
I feel very comfortable going to those
countries I've been there before there's
nothing new or mystical about it for me
and I think people feel that in you and
they appreciate it
I would agree with that and I think
that's a really good lesson I want to
just underscore for the people who are
watching I know a lot of them work
internationally unfortunately I think a
majority of the tendency you know we go
to a country and we just sort of
snowplow there they're culturally we ask
them to speak our language and big
mistake it's a big mistake yeah yeah but
just you know culturally I think
traveling internationally really rounds
you out right yeah and I've done a
little bit of travel myself and just
being in a different country you realize
oh there are different ways to do things
yep and they are good yeah and they also
if you respect their culture and then
you can make reference to your history
and they appreciate you know when I go
to Cyprus people knew I went to the
British school there and then I went to
the Cypriot school there and and I know
the street names and I know we're family
gusta isn't Carini and the beaches and
trone us and all the places where the
current population hangs out and I've
been there been going there for 30 years
that is a huge financial hub people
don't realize how big and how many
transactions occur in the Cypriot
banking system because that's where sort
of the East meets the West Russians are
very active there there's a ton of
capital for the Middle East there it's
sort of like a neutral ground but a very
important place to have relationships
yeah I know the good lesson I mean you
know when you show respect to get
respect and I'm sure that's a big part
of your success I often ask my guests
you know how do you know what you're
good at how do you know where to find
your passion because you know the sort
of the default advice is follow your
passion and that may or may not be good
advice but I think the point that you
sort of crystallized for me is sometimes
you have to do stuff that you don't like
doing to figure out what you do like
that's a great point that's an
absolutely great point and you want to
do that early in your career to
understand what motivates you the
perfect situation I mean I tell
entrepreneurs today I invest in so many
of them you know when I say to them look
you're starting this journey I want you
to understand something this is not
going to be fun all the time you're
gonna work twenty five hours a day eight
days a week because there's some die in
Mumbai or Shanghai that's gonna kick
your ass if you don't and it's forever
and it's forever but what will happen if
you're successful and you won't see it
coming you wake up one day and say oh my
goodness I I'm wealthy beyond my wildest
dreams you'll probably go right back to
work but the point is you created
something of tremendous value and the
and the way it manifests
self to you later in life is it gives
you freedom to do whatever you want my
number one message entrepreneurs and I
teach today is never pursue
entrepreneurship for the greed of money
it has nothing to do with it at all
the whole reason to be an entrepreneur
is the pursuit of freedom that's why you
do it you do it because you want to be
free one day to do whatever you like I'm
here because I want to be here I don't
have to be here I don't have to ever
listen to a phone call again if I don't
want to that's not what I want to do I
enjoy spending my time doing the things
that I want to do and I and I deserve it
because I worked like hell to get here
and so I'm a huge you know advocate of
capitalism I defend entrepreneurship
every day when people say you don't
deserve that I say [ __ ] I deserve
everything because I started with this
everything I have I created myself and I
deserve what I have and I and I feel
ferociously about that and I tell other
entrepreneurs do not be embarrassed
about success wear it own it it's yours
and you deserve it
[Music]